et kamissoko bonsoir leurs bilans 88
le film avec godard une tournée aux
états unis et quelques mois en studio
avec tony dispositif pour un nouvel
album noir domino city c'est le tube
vous avez dit avec ce titre on va passer
chez martin on fera tout on fera tout
sauf hockey est il un magazine entrevue
je comprends pas pourquoi les uns parce
que tout quand on fait tout pourquoi pas
ok nous disait que sur 7 sur cette
chanson c'est qu'on pouvait faire la
chanson chanson s'adapter c'est une
chanson qui dit que je pouvais passer
d'emploi du dossier ouais c'est comme ça
c'était par exemple cette épreuve
rock'n'roll ou un truc comme molino je
pense à avoir meilleure île morte là
mais ça je penserai plus clair et l
alien
je pense aux raids auraient pu accrocher
sur jour musique mais vous allez quoi
que les autres n'ont pas en france vous
êtes tellement différent des eaux
tellement au dessus de la mêlée vous
tranchez vous avez quoi que tu n'as pas
le trac avantage moment on est culotté
maintien alors existe qu'on vit dans la
loi ou discontinue et travaille avec
notamment un set on démarre avec
champions dont l'appel c'est pas vrai
que les autres le font passer rien n'y a
pas de creuser la tête un peu plus que
les autres
j'en sais rien
peut-être qu'on allait prendre qui pour
le clip de mondovino city chaque fois
les gens bac lui non non non fini enfin
la soirée
vous allez recevoir des coups de fil les
enfants là ce que le bon jean baptiste
on avait un retard était pas tout de
suite le jeu prend vie prometteur
[Musique]
[Rires]
tu connais la musique
[Applaudissements]
là
[Musique]
où va son palais
tu jamais acquis
[Musique]
et
elle
[Musique]
m
et
[Musique]
ma famille
m
[Musique]
voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
m
[Musique]
il
m
[Musique]
vous avez entendu parler des questions
qui ont tous les deux ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
imaginez première question premier
répond question avec tous les deux non
je la pose au delà enfin ça va être
concerne la première je pense qu'elle te
concerne a pu être plus toi c'est à dire
que un jour je décide de faire un enfant
et puis tu t'aperçois que tu peux plus
en avoir pour des raisons tu peux plus
en avoir et
tu cherches une mère porteuse et
mireille mathieu te propose d'être ta
mère porteuse est ce que tu acceptes
qu'est-ce que tu refuses d'abord je vais
faire un test et de bissy dad
oui oui sinon oui mais pas de problème
non non pourquoi non je sais pas je te
demande fut question deuxième question
est à toi si tu veux c'est vrai quoi
cette correspondante est un peu mieux
aussi qu à qui se trouve le plus de
circonstances atténuantes à un vieux qui
se tape des petits garçons pour de
l'argent ou un petit garçon qui tapent
sur des vieux toujours pour de l'argent
[Rires]
oh ça au cas aucun a des circonstances
atténuantes suis très moral finalement
quoi hein qu'est toi tu réfléchis pas
d'accord du convoi alors à toi
maintenant d'accord est-ce que tu serais
prêt à mourir maintenant la commune a
subitement 30 carrière fini nettement
pour que l'apartheid soit immédiatement
supprimées en afrique du sud
non pas que cela l'autre jour tu as posé
une question si la faim dans le monde en
prenant pirouette est prête à mourir si
on peut le faire à l'envers pour des
trucs qui sont là toute la planète
assure pas pour un pays ça vaut pas le
coup d'envoi ça va faire plaisir aux
autres
alors imaginez êtes tous les deux dans
un chalet tout c'est bien con élections
vous êtes tous les deux ans dans un
chalet de montagne puis lui les morts
mais qu'il soit tard un autre à bouffer
je le mange mais tu commences par câble
est d'accord mais je commence parfois
assez salée que mais surtout dire propos
sur la tête parce que comme ça au mois
je me paierais plus la cervelle non la
figure on ne peut pas être une bonne
caisse au gré des jeux oui parce qu'on
rit biche des biches quoi vous êtes
morts tous les jours tous les deux ou
préfèrent un cachet stone et charden
yoko agent ou pierre et marie curie
pierre et marie curie bah ouais pourquoi
l'attachement sérieux en fait
yoko
alors question qu'on traditionnel la
bande arrive dans le cinq minutes que
c'était moi je me tapais inverse de jack
daniel's puis je faire un grand baie à
catherine et puis voilà c'est toi
catherine droit d'avoir le baiser pour
l'année parce que la lune vous avez une
solution de vous échapper
juste avant que la bombe arrivé à
aberdeen vous appelle vous écouter les
gens qu a laissé crever la bombe
on vous met dans un vaisseau spatial
nous cacher des sur la lune ou sur mars
marchait pas ou là où c'est bien toi là
où il n'y a pas de bombe mais il ya
trois places dans le vaisseau spatial et
comme verdier mais bon ils nous ont pris
un troisième passage chez renault
google maintenant
ppda guy lux ou sabatier france a battu
froid avant oui pourquoi guy lux il
arrête pas il est trop tôt on va guider
jusqu'au vidéo est trop sérieux
saint-mathieu harfang darabont se joue
du xylophone le sourire sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars d'études abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu